hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game that
just ended in round six of the 2021 uh
tata still chester and alexander
donchenko versus alireza ferrugia
and uh well uh as as all the games we
show on this channel this one is also
quite the game so without further ado
let's check it out donchenko
uh with the white pieces opens with d4
and we're not gonna
dwell too long on the opening because
it's a very very long well-known uh
theoretical line uh d5 c4
with e6 uh and now knight to c3 we have
bishop to b4
uh so the queen's gambit declined this
on the board we have knight to f3 and
now black
grabs the c4 pawn so d captures on c4
and e3 uh uh dunchango goes after the c4
pawn and first
defends it so let's see uh how how this
uh
middle what are you doing
yell and i left some papers there and
now now melo is trying to
you know take advantage of the situation
so b5 and now
a4 they are challenging those advanced
pawns we have
c6 ferocious defensive and now bishop to
d2
so just continuing development this has
all been very very
analyzed with a5 and now uh a captures
on b5 with
as the b5 square is now attacked twice
so bishop captures on c3
b bishop captures on c3 and only now c
captures uh on b5 and here
b3 point being that black is unable to
play
b4 and c3 because the rook on a8 is
undefended so here white would just play
bishop captures on b4
and white would have an extremely uh
well
great position so here instead after
this b3 by white we have bishop to b7 by
furuja again
this has all been played before uh b
captures uh on c4 and now
uh b4 so here black gets the two
connected past pawns but white
gets a massive center so a bit of a
trade-off the shabbat to b2
and now knight to f6 ferruccio continues
development prepares castling and so on
we have bishop to d3 white also wants
the castle and now
castles and castles uh we have knight
beat to d7
and now knight to d2 uh we have e5 by
black
taking advantage of the knight moving
from f3 so we want to strike here in the
center
and bishop back to c2 and here uh
queen to c7 so this position has been
reached several times and there are a
couple of very
popular options here bishop to a4 is a
known move uh
advancing in the center with d5 is a
known f4 is a known move
uh and some of the other lesser played
ones but here h3 the move on chanco
played is a new move
so uh as of move 17 we have a completely
new game and this is basically where our
game starts
as both of them knew all of this by
heart uh most likely
so here uh alireza continues by bringing
the rook into the game
rook after e8 uh and now comes a bishop
to b3
so uh putting more uh getting more
uh defense to this c4 pawn getting the
bishop on this diagonal
and also you you just keep an eye on
everything this is defended the a4
square is nicely defended so black
cannot just advance that a pawn
and you wait and see what black will do
yeah furuja goes to h6
and now knight back to f3 so here you're
kind of trying to bait
this e4 move but e4 doesn't really do
anything for black it just
closes up this light square diagonal
which is not something you want to do
and it's a question whether this pawn
will be a a weakness or a string but
most likely a weakness why can play
this take away this bishop's defense of
the pawn then
attacked the pawn uh several times and
it's just gonna be
uh a problem for black to defend it so
instead after a knight of three we have
rooked
a6 first doesn't even bother defending
the pawn
he offers it and now uh let's see what
happens here
so dunchenko decides to grab the pawn we
have knight captures on e5
knight captures and d captures on e5
attacking the knight here
knight to d7 and now f4 and it seems
like a
a a very strong position for white uh a
lot of presence in the center here
uh if c5 is played you can even uh get
both of these bishops fully operational
so white has something to play for uh
ferruccio goes knights the c5
blocks the pawn and also prepares to
bring the knight over to the central e4
square
bishop to c2 and the now uh a4
uh continuing to advance those spawns so
this is what furuja had in mind when he
sacrificed that pawn
and it does seem black has plenty of
compensation so here
f5 by dunchenko he continues the attack
he wants to play e6
and now b3 by furuja here you're
basically deciding between b3 and a3
furuja goes b3 bishop back to b1
and now rook a back to a8 here
a3 would be interesting uh
if you want to trade everything down for
example captures captures captures
and then rook captures on e5 or rather
queen captures on e5 even better
this is what would happen if furuja went
for a3 but furuja for the moment uh
wants to keep uh both of his pawns
so he goes back rook 888 probably with
the idea of bringing the other rook into
the attack with rook to d8 and now e6
uh white continues the attack so saying
that maybe rook to a8 was just a little
bit slow
uh we have queen to g3 by feruja setting
up
setting up a nice checkmate here as the
bishop and queen are attacking the pawn
and here white should defend with queen
to e2 but it's hard to
realize that when when we just enter
this position so here
uh white defender would rook to f2 but
this allows uh firuja a very sneaky idea
first he blocks off
the attack with f6 not allowing the
capture and also now
uh both of the bishops are blocked and
now white is the one
black is the one who will try to attack
uh we have bishop to d4
by dunchenko and now knights the e4 with
an attack on the rook here
so here white creates with captures
captures and
now rook to a3 again you don't want to
allow a three so you block it with the
rook
it seems like a very passive square for
the rook but if you want to stop those
queen side pawns you have to play
something
uh and here we have rook e the c8 now
going after this
c pawn here we have c5 dunchenko defends
it
by advancing it and now king to h7 the
king will be much safer here on h7
uh we have queen to d2 now adding
another defender to the second rank but
here
uh here we uh get to the position from
the thumbnail here
uh firuja played b2 and it's such a
weird move to play
uh rook to d8 seems like seems like the
way to go or even the rook c to b8
preparing to push the pawn
uh but here firuja plays the move that i
often characterize as a tall move
uh as it's something uh not everyone
would play
not not a lot of people would even
consider this move because uh
well the b2 square is defended three
times so
uh what do you what do you gain by
actually playing b3 other than giving up
a pawn
so here uh obviously if uh the b2 pawn
is captured
for example with the bishop then rook
captures on c5
and it seems like black definitely has
compensation the rook can can now come
to c2 the other rook can come to c8 you
can double up rooks here
and it it seems that uh black is
definitely getting something plus he
eliminated the past c
pawn however uh donchenko said all right
i'm not i'm not going to capture it with
the bishop i'm going to capture it with
the queen
and it doesn't seem like furuja has
anything here
so he captured with the queen but now
the position is completely lost for
white
but it's uh it's uh the you know how far
furuga saw
that this pawn cannot be captured by the
queen is just
amazing so feel free to pause the video
and find the winning move for furuja
here
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting all
the way to
the move and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's
rook to b8 either of the rooks will do
so either rook a or rook c to b8
uh wins the game for black point is
after what was played in the game rook
a to b8 you have to move the queen so
queen to 82 was played and now comes
rook to b1 with check that was the point
of bringing the queen over to b2 so you
have
rook to b8 with tempo and now you bring
the rook to b1 again with tempo so the
the white king is in check
rook to f1 so dunchenko defends
everything defends against check
checkmate still being defended uh and
now rook
c the b8 so threatening just capture
here followed by uh rook to b1 or if the
queen
remains there even uh just uh dropping
the rook uh
okay so the bishop for the moment is
defending that uh but
just uh give you an idea if you play
something weird uh even
rook eight to b2 is enough because uh
the the queen can never
uh not be defending the b2 square so
even if the bishop captures then it's
just checkmate so
uh rook to b2 would definitely be a
scary threat so here queen to f2 was
played now saying okay you can
do uh drop the rook the rook all the way
to b1 my queen will be defending against
checkmate
but now rook captures on f1 with check
king captures uh of course if the queen
captures then just work to b1 or even
bishop captures and g2 is enough there
is nothing you can do here
if the queen captures then rook to b1 is
indeed checkmate
there is nothing to to block the check
with so here after rook capture son
f1 we have king captures on f1 and now
rook to b1 with check king to e2 and now
comes the move furuja had to see
before he played the b2 upon the b2 move
uh because this is the only move now
that uh wins for black and that move is
i'm sure you'll see it now once i've
mentioned it
queen the b8 this is what furuja played
and now there is no defense against
queen to b5 check bishop covers f3 rook
covers f1
and queen to b5 will be deadly so here
uh there's nothing you can do if you
just ignore it for example with e7 then
like i said queen b5 check and that's it
king d2 you're going to get queen to c4
threatening uh checkmate and if that is
defended
with some sort of a move here then just
queen a to check rook has to block and
this is now checkmate so
ignoring the threat rarely helps and
also it doesn't help here
so queen to f4 was played freeing up the
f2 square for the
for the white king but now queen to b5
with check and again it doesn't really
help if you go here then it's still just
queen to f1 with
check you have to go up the board and
queen captures on g to check
king h4 and now rook to h1 will uh
be game over there's no way to defend
against this even queen g3 just the rook
captures and that's it
queen captures on h3 queen to g5 is
checkmate
so everything ends in checkmate here so
after queen to b5 check
you don't really gain anything by king
f2 so king the d2 was played
uh but now comes queen to be for with
check and now this comes with
check also the rook is under attack but
it doesn't matter you're getting
checkmated whatever you play
so here dunchenko tried sacrificing the
rook to survive a little bit longer
queen captures on a3 and now queen
captures on e4 eliminating that bishop
but it doesn't help queen to c1 checked
king to d3
and now queen to f1 with check and it
was in this position on mu 43 that
alexander donchenko resigned in the game
and
a great great victory for alireza firuja
as
the white king has nowhere to go you
could of course uh go to c2 or d1 then
queen to d1 is checkmate
and if you go up the board it doesn't
help rook to d1 check and the king has
nowhere to go
this is covered by the queen this spawn
this is rook you have to block and then
it's just checkmate uh
brilliant brilliant the game and the
brilliant attack by faruja he was able
to trick
donchenko with that tal move let's see
it one more time
maybe not in slow motion it's a pawn
move so let's just push it like
pawn to b2 really amazing stuff
and it's such a weird move to play
because it it's just defended three
times so
even considering this just shows how uh
how
well uh uh you know uh felucia is
planning these attacks and the
there's nothing wrong with the move
white can just play a bad move or or or
you know you know maybe a lesser move
but
there are no good moves here for uh for
why just capturing with the bishop is
best but
uh dunchenko tried to keep everything
and then he lost everything
uh so yeah uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it i would like to thank
connor jolie
joseph governor and david kimura isle
goodman and alima casanova for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the tata
steel
uh checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens
in the chess world uh so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day